ils ont tous avancer leurs pions pour
tenter de s'emparer du roi de leurs
adversaires ce mercredi 24 mars ces
parties étaient organisées à coignard à
l'occasion des championnats scolaires
académique d'échec dans la salle une
centaine de joueurs de 6 à 15 ans venus
de toute l'académie de versailles on a
une partie du genre de club donc c'est
des équipes de 8 2 les premiers
échiquiers sont souvent des idées des
joueurs expérimentés et les derniers
échiquier sondés vraiment des enfants
qui ont découvert les échecs sur le
temps scolaire et qui découvrent la
compétition parmi ces rois de la
stratégie des yvelinois des écoles de
coignières encore ce collège de montfort
l'amaury étaient qualifiés pour ce
championnat ces joueurs fout de ce jeu
de plus le plus jeune âge est très à
cheval sur les règles ont leurs
techniques pour devenir les futurs
maîtres de cette discipline il faut
beaucoup d'entraînement il faut lier
beaucoup de livres dessus et faut
surtout bon sans beaucoup d'entraînement
c'est ce qui est le plus important est
bien connaître les règles le but c'est
pas de devenir force et de s'amuser en
jouant et c'est comme ça justement qu on
devient fort et on s'entraînant et en
faisant des défaites parce que c'est là
c'est la voie pour gagner les vainqueurs
des écoles se sont qualifiés pour la
grande finale nationale programmée à
brissac dans l'hérault la compétition
sera organisée en juin prochain il reste
donc un peu de temps pour réviser ses
stratégies